Dina is with us in st. Louis hi Dina how
are you hi day thank you I'm good thanks
for taking my call
sure what's up and so my husband and I
just read you're a tunnel money makeover
book and we're really excited and we
have a lot of debt to knock out and we
want to get to the plan right away cool
my my husband just started a new job and
as part of that job he got a thirty
thousand dollar sign on bonus auction
and yeah it's great
it'll it'll it'll really help with our
plans
however so my question is and so we'd
have a lot of debt not including our two
mortgages we have student loan and
credit cards that total over four
hundred twenty thousand dollars and like
I said not only I'm not driving by that
I can't breathe how much is - how much
is student loans 336,000
so who's the doctor lawyer my husband
what is he here I don't have a doctor
he's yeah he's got his hmm what is it
what is he making what is he 300 that's
good news
all right and and he got a thirty
thousand dollar signing bonus and then
we have another seventy thousand in
credit card debt yeah okay all right and
how much on the cars so that and that's
where my question comes is I do have two
car fleeces of course and one is and
it's we pay 1,400 a month in total for
both of those and one of those is up in
December of this year and one is up in
May of next year okay and what is the
what's the buyout on them at the end of
the lease do you know you know I do not
know I know it's always well over what
they're actually worth so and so your
plan to turn them in we do okay we do
plan to turn them in if you make 300
thousand a year yeah yeah how much is
your house payment well we have two
mortgages one is the one we live in
which is two thousand
and the other one is about the it's I
think it's 2,300 it was I'm not going to
get all the terms correctly but we had
an arm
it was after 10 years we had the balloon
you have two mortgages on one house or
two different well I'm sorry we have a
second home that we rent it's rented out
okay however that one's a long story
because the the rent does not cover what
is what is now the mortgage so Charlotte
know even though it's underwater
how much underwater is it it's only
worth about two-thirds of what we owe on
it
who said realtor like recently just
about two months ago where is it it's in
the suburbs of Chicago okay
that's unusual unless you just I mean it
usually most of those values have
recovered in that area so that's a
little weird I mean you must have
already you must have borrowed more on
it than it was worth to start with or
something well I don't I mean at the
time it was you know we we bought it in
2005 it went up about in value about you
know 10 or 20 grams just a few months
after we bought it and then about three
years after that it went way down a lot
of the homes it's a townhome and a lot
of the homes in our area have been short
sales okay alright so to take a little
bit longer to recover so you're going to
be you're going to be feeding it awhile
what's it rent for 1750 okay so you're
feeding five hundred bucks a month so
six thousand dollars a year out of your
three hundred thousand goes to that
until it's gone until you can get it
sold right so you're going to lose six
thousand bucks here that doesn't matter
than kill you it's just a paint it's
just a pain in the butt the other stuff
is killing you okay so we need to buy a
car in December right correct and then
again in May okay um but but we have
thirty thousand dollars did we set some
of that aside for a car yeah I I was set
ten aside for Dee no this is this is
fabulous is March no no I'm not going to
set anything aside you can see listen
your take-home pay is
twenty-five thousand dollars a month now
you take on page 23 is $17,000 a month
right
yeah it's around and we've only gotten I
think he just started this new job no
it's only it's around yeah so my point
is save us in the fall set ten thousand
dollars aside and buy a car in December
and later in the spring set ten thousand
dollars aside and buy a car in May but
for right now let's throw the thirty
thousand at this credit card debt okay
and list your debts smallest to largest
and you guys aren't you cannot live like
doctors anymore we want your broken up
planning here you are broke you've been
you've been spending money like you were
in Congress or something yeah it's
embarrassing yeah
and so it's it's the great news is you
have a great shovel the bad news is you
have a great hole yeah and you can dig
out of it but you're going to have to
live like college students instead of
doctors and so the vacations are gone
the eating out all the time is gone the
fine wine is gone you stop it until you
get this dadgum mess cleaned up
okay and if you do that you'll be out of
it in no time and you're going to be so
wealthy you won't be able to breathe and
you'll be able to help a lot of people
and you'll have a great life and you
won't feel financially shamed all the
time by your looking in the mirror you
know what I'm saying
well there's no reason to be like this
you can you can do this you're gonna do
great at it I'm proud of you already so
you're already asking questions if
you're both on board but listen the
formula I mean dumb people don't get to
where your husband is and anywhere you
are okay you guys are smart people
you've just done some dumb things that
the formula is this the deeper you
sacrifice the faster you're out right
yeah so my i'ma rip the band-aid off guy
the faster you can get out of this mess
the more the pain is limited and then
the faster you get on to enjoying your
wealth which of course includes
outrageous generosity you're going to be
a position to do so much good not only
for your whole family tree but but but
for people around you you know that
right yes yes we're looking forward to
that we want that and you know your two
years of hell
away from that maybe three but somewhere
in there to clean this mess up but if
you live on nothing you can clean up
four hundred thousand making three
hundred thousand two hundred thousand a
year right is two years you're done
that's living on a hundred break my Ark
not counting taxes okay Obama's going to
take half your dadgum money so we're not
counting that but you know but but the
deal is that you can do this you it's
probably it's probably a three year plan
in reality because taxes are going to
slay you but um you can do this and yes
I'd set ten thousand aside in the fall
but let's go ahead and get some progress
and get your confidence built up and you
start looking at yourself in the mirror
being feeling proud of the way you
handle money maybe for the first time or
the first time in a while anyway and you
go yeah we're going to do this yes we're
going to be like grown-ups and you're
going to just knock on the crap because
see I think your credit card free before
Christmas I think you can make them yeah
that'd be great
I thought that and you got a car paid
for so you got rid of one of the leases
at Christmas and the credit cards are
all gone now we got to do is one car in
May and knock the rest these stupid
student loans out and you're going to do
it you're going to do it and you're
going to call back and you have a great
debt free scream story I can't wait to
hear the story well thank you I look
forward to that will make the trip okay
you let me let me know if I can help
okay okay thank you so much Dave
appreciate it thanks for calling in hey
you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you're
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right it's kind of
better
same room to channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget one of the best videos out there
you